all
sì
la musica polifonica è una bella
scommessa
a maggior ragione se si fa a cappella
ovvero senza l'ausilio di strumenti
musicali come avete sentito con le sole
voci la nostra avventura con la musica
polifonica comincia oltre 20 anni fa in
un liceo classico catanese ma la
passione per il canto non è l'unica nota
che ci contraddistingue infatti come
avete sentito noi facciamo una musica un
po particolare abbiamo gli abbiamo
presentato un brano rinascimentale il
grosso del nostro repertorio e per
l'appunto prevalentemente rinascimentale
perché dico che una scommessa questo
tipo di musica perché non è certo una
musica che si ascolta tutti i giorni
non capita infatti di sentirla spesso
alla radio non possa spesso alla radio
non passa spesso in televisione ea volte
a un primo ascolto può risultare un po
difficile
qui da noi poi in particolare dove
l'esperienza corale non è così diffusa
come per esempio nei paesi del nord
europa o ancora in america dove la
tradizione corale è una tradizione molto
ben radicata e ben sentita per me poi in
particolare un'altra scommessa è stato è
stata il coinvolgere dei ragazzi degli
adolescenti a questo tipo di musica
ricordo infatti che quando facevo loro
il provino per prenderli all'interno
del coro e dicevo loro che tipo di
musica
avremmo fatto mi guardavano come se
fossi un extraterrestre un'aliena si va
bene musica rinascimentale cos'è e
pensavano che subito dopo il provino se
la sarebbero data a gambe e sarebbero
scappati invece restavano e molti di
loro sono ancora qui dopo quasi 20 anni
ma cos'è davvero la polifonia ovviamente
la parola stessa ci dice che sono molte
voci che suonano insieme ma è qualcosa
di ancora più profondo e l'incontro di
voci diverse
tecnicamente di melodie diverse che però
funzionano bene insieme
anzi che spesso non funzionano affatto
se non insieme è bella questa cosa che
cose diverse funzionino bene insieme in
un incontro collettivo è un po lo
specchio di ciò che dovrebbe essere
nella vita nella nostra vita
l'incontro fra le diversità infatti
dovrebbe essere sinonimo di
arricchimento mentre spesso invece
diventa sinonimo di di scontro e di
conflitto e se questo conflitto ancora
dovesse essere il risultato dovesse
essere positivo sarebbe ancora bello in
musica ad esempio ci sono le dissonanze
le dissonanze quando risolvono sono
belle ma nella vita spesso non è così e
il conflitto spesso è generato soltanto
dalla paura invece del diverso di ciò
che non è come noi e allora diventa
diventa povertà diventa fuga diventa
miseria della persona umana
per capire meglio però in pratica come
funziona la polifonia abbiamo pensato di
preparare un brano prima spezzettandolo
cioè facendovi ascoltare le singole
parti e dopo facendolo suonare tutti
insieme vi presenteremo un brano del
quindicesimo secolo tourdion
un canto di taverna in cui si inneggia
al piacere del bere
lo presenteremo a voci prima separate
eseguiranno la melodia prima i bassi poi
tenori poi i contratti infine i soprani
e alla fine sentirete come suonano tutte
le voci insieme
mangiando a se raccontasse la combo a
sera con il convegno sarà un action to
you tube di santo o mangia rosa un po
assi la contesa amico torre tornato al
return così tesa ma c'e quella barba
sono sapevo non saprò come sola che
abbiamo
a fianco
cosa voglio cantare ancora giocatore
torna o si vedono sempre cosi
grazie cantele fa bene questo lo sanno
tutti
infatti si dice canta che ti passa
quello che forse alcuni non sanno è che
per cantare e soprattutto per cantare in
polifonia il primo requisito è saper
ascoltare l'ascolto per noi uomini del
2000 è una dimensione molto molto
difficile molto rara tutti infatti amano
parlare esibirsi dire qualcosa esporsi
ma quanti ascoltano e fra quelli che
ascoltano quanti ascoltano davvero anche
i nostri ambienti se ci facciamo caso
sono pieni di quella che si chiama
musica di sottofondo i locali ristoranti
centri commerciali dappertutto sentiamo
questo frastuono assordante che in
realtà altro non è e altra funzione non
sa che quella di sviarci da noi stessi
l'ascolto dunque difficile richiede
pazienza richiede tolleranza richiede
disponibilità e una capacità di farsi un
passo indietro perché in qualche momento
bisogna dare spazio all'altro quindi
richiede umiltà e anche un infinito
allenamento direi più del cantare stesso
l'ascoltare non è solo una funzione
specifica dell'orecchio ascoltare non è
sinonimo di udire è un requisito
fondamentale per per che dimostra la
capacità di entrare in relazione con
l'altro con il mondo in modo autentico
profondo disinteressato e anche a mio
avviso amorevole
forse oso tanto dicendo che ascoltare è
il primo passo per saper amare allora
cantare per noi è sicuramente in primo
luogo un divertimento ma è anche uno
strumento per formarsi con il supporto
magico e la musica ci offre è anche un
mezzo per entrare in relazione per
abbassare le barriere per allentare le
tensioni e renderci più più capaci di
ascoltare e di comunicare cantare in
polifonia
inoltre è un tendere l'orecchio verso la
complessità della vita la vita con tutte
le sue sfaccettature
la vita che spesso è ricca di
contraddizioni e e per noi cantare in
polifonia rappresenta tutto questo e
soprattutto è la ricchezza della
diversità
lì dove la diversità è uguale
all'armonia per salutarvi
abbiamo preparato un brano
esemplificativo di tutto questo
il cui titolo è lisciandro del
compositore franco fiammingo clima
motionscan del 500 in cui sentirete il
verso onomatopeico degli uccelli
o
rossi